yeah well this is where
everyone is trying to get to to get out
and it's really really difficult to get
here uh they come through and uh they
have to show their paperwork it looks
fairly chaotic it's fairly chaotic but
they've at least
restored some order basically the
various nationalities who arrive here
say which country they're from and if
there's various translators there's
turkish soldiers here's american
soldiers british of course spanish they
then try to speak to the nationals check
out their paperwork and if it works out
they'll let them through what's really
interesting is there this was absolutely
chaos until they got this barricade in
place
and what's really peculiar about this is
it's just how near the taliban are in
fact the british soldiers have gone
slightly forward i think they're
negotiating with the taliban now
in fact though they are speaking to the
commanders i can see them um
there have been huge huge crowds here
the taliban has brought some control but
you can probably see in the distance
they're standing on their trucks
and they're firing into the air
now there must be another
push of people coming through
and uh
yeah you can hear it
for a lot of these british soldiers of
course a lot of the american soldiers as
well they've been fighting taliban not
for 20 years these guys are way too
young but uh this is a remarkable thing
that the the only way that any type of
calm has been restored here is because
uh the british and the taliban are
actually coordinating uh this operation
uh and
the real big question is how long is it
going to go on for how many people are
they going to process we're already
seeing people being rejected and it's
heartbreaking stuff and those children
crying and going out it's it's a pretty
pretty intense time